So far we have looked at simple mathematical operations of trying to
do point processes across images or looking at neighborhoods of images or
neighborhoods of pixels to be able to do simple mathematics on it.
Now let's try to create a formal mathematical representation of it.
For that purpose,
I'm going to introduce the concept of cross-correlation leading up to
the concept of convolution.
These will provide us with simple mathematical formulations and
mathematical tools that will allow us to do things like smoothing images,
kind of doing blurring on images, and
also reducing noise and finding different types of information from images.